largest teaching nine thousand short in
the state of florida industry experts
say the problem is pretty simple nobody
wants to be a teacher anymore for
multiple reasons it seemed less and less
like a viable fulfilling career option
the regional director of teach for
america said the solution is simple take
steps to make teaching an attractive
career once again a florida education
association report has shown more than 9
500 teaching
and support staff positions across the
state of florida are vacant it says the
shortage is so wild wide-ranging that
more than 450 000 florida students
may have started last school year
without full-time certified teachers in
their classroom a survey of high school
students found that only five percent
were interested in becoming teachers and
that survey was from four years ago what
do you think is going on here with these
teachers i am
i think it speaks to
where we are
and i hate to go back to the same thing
but
that's a great gig
that's a great gig it's a nice job
that's an honorable profession no money
it's fun
it's it's you're you're you're changing
lives and if we're at a place in this
country where we can't get people to
want to take a decent
job yeah you're not going to make a lot
of money i mean but they get it
too if you're latino you're making a lot
of money yeah i remember once
i was listening to um god who's the big
tall guy who used to be on fox news he
and i used to go at it all the time uh
o'reilly right
bill o'reilly and i remember
he went on he was interviewed once and
he said i grew up i grew up poor in
america my dad was a a postman he was
the the letter carrier you know mailman
as we used to call him
um
and i thought to myself
that's poor
as a latino my dad my dad cleaned
toilets at the barcelona hotel on miami
beach and in the daytime he was also
working as a busboy and then he had a
job driving a truck at night bill that's
what my dad did stop telling people that
because your dad is a mailman you grew
up poor because you certainly didn't
grow up poor
this mindset not to pick on you vinnie
because i love you like a brother pero
this mindset that oh my god she's a
teacher she doesn't make a lot of money
that's damn good money they make thirty
forty fifty thousand dollars i don't
care that's that's pretty good money you
can make a living and you could raise a
family out of that but if i had a
it was a couple why don't people want
these jobs is what i'm saying pat
they're underappreciated they don't like
do the teacher i think is is one of the
most important things to give people
dude teachers made us and we talked
about it they don't get they don't get
the acknowledgement they don't get the
credit and i'm sorry 30 40 50 000 in
this in this day and age is nothing and
they i think it's like you said they're
reinventing and they're moving a certain
way
i know a lot of latino friends of mine
who would die for thirty five thousand
dollar job and by the way
appreciated tell them like work in
florida if you wanna be appreciated get
a dog okay just you know
you know you've got an opportunity to do
something you've got an opportunity to
make a difference you get to go to work
sit in a place that's air-conditioned
every day affect people's lives and
you're going to say no that's beneath me
come on now there's something wrong with
our country if that's been rick there's
a lot of latinos in florida one of you
want to become teachers
exactly why do you think this is
happening
anything outside of what we've said
why do you think this is happening
it's interesting i mean you look at um
you look at the people that are becoming
teachers now and they're more and more
activists they're more and more focused
on themselves they want to project their
beliefs onto kids they want to you know
it's like you see
libs of tick tock is a funny one but
really look at the the average teacher
who's teaching kids now coming out of
college they're activists they're not
interested in
helping the youth grow and really
educate and help them learn they're
interested in indoctrinating them and i
think there's
i think there's been an interesting
loss of that idea of actually educating
not just indoctrinating not just pushing
beliefs but actually teaching somebody
something history uh the great classic
works i mean how to
be a better person i mean like really
true education
and i think there's
such an interest in myself pushing what
i believe pushing my personal desires
onto people that yeah you know you know
what i'm you know i kind of butchered it
but if it makes sense i mean there's a
few ways i i i think about this one if
this is the if you think about 9 000
teachers to me
how many students per teacher is it fair
to say 30 i'd say 30. okay so that's 270
000 kids right if you think about it
there's 270 000 kids if it's 9 000
teachers short so are you doing the
numbers to see what it is
uh one in 15 is that what it is in you
in florida okay so 9015 135 so let's
just say 150 to 300 000 students are
being affected by this okay
so how do you handle this do you handle
it by
giving a bump do you handle it by
lowering the requirement to be a teacher
uh do we get the data to see these nine
thousand student nine thousand teachers
that is shortage is it in elementary is
it in junior high is it in high school
what's the breakdown what's the
definition of a teacher could it be
kindergarten how are they processing
this and then if you're thinking about
the future of education does this mean
the education route has to be changed
is it more online is it more
homeschooling what direction is this
going to be going because
a lot of these types of stats that you
see is a byproduct of
certain you know laws certain new
guidelines rules a direction certain
industry is going where people say i
just want to do i don't want to do this
job i'd be so interested to know more of
the data of what category these 9 000
teachers are in
i'd be curious to know
but to me 9 000
i don't know how far the story is going
to go how much more we're going to hear
some data yeah so we want to go data
with it so what percentage of teachers
do you think are women
most
seventy-five percent are women majority
okay so and the average age of a teacher
is 42 years old yeah so if i'm a woman
and i'm in my early 30s mid-30s
42 is the average
and i'm looking and i'm seeing what's
going on all around me on you said the
libs of tick tock right all right so if
i'm a
attractive kindergarten teacher and i'm
making 42 grand a year
and i'm overworked i'm underpaid yeah i
get the summers off that's cool and i'm
looking around and i'm going down the
conspiracy rabbit hole here but i'm a
young attractive woman
and i see what's going on at girls on
only fans and covid and lockdown and
masks and kids and snot and flu and
covid
and
becky down the street is uh doing only
fans 250. yeah exactly just printing
money showing off her
and she's like you know what [ __ ] this
i'm out i'm gonna go do something else
i'm gonna go i'm not saying that they're
only in the room what kind of school did
you go to where every female teacher was
hot there's some i'm just saying sorry
what seven did you go to like
hooters junior high school
obviously you didn't meet mrs mcelveen
you know well i grew up in what i had
but
i it wasn't everybody but the big
difference
the reality is most teachers are females
and they're just like but if you're if
we've got but if we come over this
nonsense if we've gotten to a point in
this country where you're gonna turn
down as i'm reading here an average
salary starting salary in the state of
florida between forty four thousand and
fifty one thousand dollars because
some ideal and the summer's off as you
said because you have some oh i don't
like the way they're saying this or i
don't like the way they're doing that i
don't know man what do you mean like
they don't like the way they're saying
well whatever whatever it is that they
don't like they don't like the fact that
the the whatever the political argument
of the of the moment is i mean
my gosh it still seems to me like you're
passing up on a hell of an opportunity
yeah you know so what does that say
about our society that people don't need
that job once again the rick sanchez
agua media message we need more mexicans
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]